okay do you think you have enough blood
there seven months ten-year-old Oscar
has been coming to terms with type 1
diabetes this comes from Denmark it's my
first acting incident yes but as well as
the anxiety of illness his family is
also facing uncertainty over brexit
every piece of equipment and medicine he
relies on is made in Europe as yet there
are no guarantees that will continue if
there is no deal I I didn't really think
I was gonna affect me a lot I thought it
was just gonna affect the way they
everything went to the country but I
didn't think I was gonna affect a tons
and how do you feel about the idea that
it might make it hard as the other
medicine you need think it's crazy
hospital trusts have written to NHS
leaders and ministers complaining about
a lack of planning for No Deal and
warning that medical supplies could be
adversely affected the UK exports 45
million packets of medicines to Europe
every month with another 37 million
packets coming the other way for some
drugs like insulin the UK is almost
wholly reliant on imports including from
suppliers in Germany Denmark and France
stockpiling and flying goods in from the
EU may actually be drastic as they sound
quite sensible precautions which might
help to avoid some that impact in
patients how worried we should be is a
matter of debate even it seems within
government you will see when we set out
our plans some of these hair-raising
scare stories are very far from the
truth it's not scare mongering there are
legitimate concerns out there hospitals
at the sharp end of the NHS say they're
desperate for guidance on how to cope
with a No Deal brexit and that could
start coming as soon as Thursday when
the government's expected to begin
setting out a series of technical papers
on everything from blood safety the
movement of organs and the testing and
regulation of medicines what families
want to know is whether they'll still
get their medicines I've certainly
looked into travelling abroad if we
needed to to get insulin
but it seems astonishing to me that in
2018 we're not having to consider
ourselves potentially medical refugees
we've simply been given no solid
reassurance from the politicians who are
in charge of this brexit juggernaut Paul
Kelso Sky News